dépassement de soi découverte et
rencontre c'est ce qui attend les 14
binômes d'aventurière au départ du
rallye naturel aventure une compétition
alliant conduite de véhicules
électriques et étape en trek mais avant
le grand départ le 4 juin prochain leur
est à la préparation pendant une journée
et demi elles vont suivre une formation
par notre directeur sportif est plongée
au cœur d'une mini aventure d'une
journée et demi pour comprendre
finalement le challenge en lui-même et
en général quand elle sort de la prime
journée de nuit elles sont rassurées et
prêtes à démarrer l'aventure lire des
cartes naviguer avec un livre de route
utilisait des boussoles ou encore
conduire de manière éco-responsable
autant de compétences qui ne
s'improvisent pas sur la ligne de départ
plusieurs yvelinoises avec leur binôme
alors on se connaît depuis presque
vingtaine d'années
on a on a fait les études ensemble la
même université à Orléans on est monté
sur Paris dans le début au milieu des
années 2000 toutes les deux passionnés
de voiture a envie de faire des
challenges on a déjà fait ensemble des
courses à pied notre entreprise BMW
Florence doré nous ont proposé ce
challenge lors de la journée des femmes
on se connaissait pas on a discuté on
s'est fait un petit déjeuner un petit
resto et hop là on s'est retrouvé on
s'est dit hop on peut faire le challenge
voilà
une compétition de 5 jours avec un
classement quotidien et final mais pour
ces femmes c'est avant tout une aventure
humaine on est trop sur nos téléphones
et on ne fait pas attention à ce qu'ils
nous entoure justement là on va observer
la nature on va observer les gens on va
les écouter et je pense que c'est ce qui
nous manque aujourd'hui là on a amène la
femme le véhicule et l'environnement en
même temps en plus avec un côté
électrique qui est très très forte
aujourd'hui d'actualité on a toutes les
deux défis je pense que c'est important
l'exemple qu'on donne à nos enfants à
chaque inscription naturelle aventure
reverse une partie des frais à
maternelle une association créée en
support du rallye elle a vocation a
soutenir des projets en faveur de
l'environnement cette année pour 2023
c'est un partenariat avec la clairière
paysanne à Magny-les-Hameaux et ça a
permis de financer du matériel agricole
pour leur activité plus particulièrement
pendant le rallye où on va aller sur la
région Savoie Haute-Savoie travailler
avec les villes partenaires Annecy et
Vian l'année dernière 3000 euros ont été
récoltés si vous souhaitez vous lancer
le défi naturel Aventure propose
également une édition en Norvège le
départ est prévu le 19 août prochain